comenzó en francia el juicio contra los
presuntos cómplices del ataque de
terroristas de 2015 a las revistas
satíricas charly esto que continuó con
una serie de asaltos que dejaron 17
muertos 14 personas están acusadas de
haber brindado supuesto apoyo a los
autores materiales de los ataques que
fueron motivados por la publicación de
una caricatura de mahoma ampliaremos
esta información desde parís
tiene una nueva visita a la ciudad de
que no ya en wisconsin es en ayuda
nuevas manifestaciones anti raciales y
contra la violencia policial tras un
nuevo ataque por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad a un hombre afroamericano en
el presidente de donald trump calificó a
las protestas como terrorismo doméstico
y prometió además ayuda económica para
el estado
y en otra entrega de nuestros informes
sobre la cultura en medio de la pandemia
hoy vamos a brasil donde el carnaval la
manifestación cultural icónica y más
emblemática del país está siendo
amenazada varias ciudades ya
suspendieron las fiestas y se espera que
se pronuncien desde las grandes ligas de
río de janeiro
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 saludamos a toda
nuestra audiencia muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos como siempre si santiago
ariztía y comenzamos esta emisión en
francia donde la justicia del país
sienta en el banquillo a los presuntos
cómplices del ataque terrorista
perpetrado en 2015 contra las revistas
satíricas charlie hebdo y que continuó
recordemos con un asalto a un
supermercado y también con el ataque a
una mujer policía dejando 17 personas
muertas en una serie de hechos que
todavía conmueven a todo el país y cuya
motivación recordemos fue la publicación
de una caricatura de mahoma el tribunal
penal evaluará hasta el 10 de noviembre
el rol de 14 personas acusadas de haber
brindado supuesto apoyo logístico a los
tres autores materiales de los ataques
que murieron durante los hechos diez de
los acusados se encuentran detenidos
provisionalmente uno en libertad bajo
control judicial y tres se encuentran
bajo orden de búsqueda y captura todos
se enfrentan a acusaciones de
participación en una organización
terrorista criminal en distintos grados
de complicidad
días de terror para los franceses el
primer ataque recordemos ocurrió el 7 de
enero y mató a 12 personas en el
semanario un día después fue asesinado a
un agente de policía municipal mientras
que el 9 de enero mataron a cuatro
personas en un supermercado judío desde
parís la capital francesa eric a
olavarría nos amplía la información
se trata de un proceso histórico en
contra de 14 personas acusadas de haber
participado material o intelectualmente
en la serie de ataques yihadistas que
tuvo lugar en enero del año 2015 en
parís en contra de la revista satírica
saliendo pero también en contra de un
supermercado judío de la post de bánzer
y en contra de una policía en el sur de
parís de esas personas tres están
ausentes una de ellas es una mujer
hallazgo media en considerada la esposa
religiosa de amedik oliva lee el autor
de la toma de rehenes y del ataque en
contra del supermercado judío y de la
muerte de la policía en la comuna de
movus al sur de parís
ella se encuentra fuera de los radares
de la policía se presume que está en
zona sirio iraquí y una hija dista
francesa que volvió hace poco a
territorio galo dice haberla visto con
vida a los otros son los hermanos
belushi mohamed el mayor está acusado de
ser el mentor de amélie olivelli y de
ser un apoyo clave en el atentado que él
realizó contra el supermercado
y su hermano menor mehdi es quien sacó
de territorio francés una semana antes
de los atentados ha hallado medio en
dirección a turquía pasando por madrid
el resto de los acusados pertenecen en
su mayoría al entorno de ahmed y juli
valley pero hay uno que es muy
importante ali resa bolat 1 franco turco
que habría sido el único vínculo entre
los hermanos quay y autores de la
matanza contra charlie hebdo y ahmed y q
libalis en el siguiente informe vamos a
conocer la heroica actuación de la sana
batilly trabajador de una tienda cuya
acción permitió salvar varias vidas en
los atentados que sufrió parís en 2015 y
ahora será un testigo en este juicio que
comenzó este miércoles conozcamos la
historia
cerca de la una de la tarde del 9 de
enero de 2015
américo olivari entró en el supermercado
ubicado en porte vansen con un rifle de
asalto disparó y mató a cuatro personas
tomó 28 rehenes entre ellos la sana
batir y un empleado de local en medio de
la confusión el joven maliense logra
esconder seis rehenes entre ellos un
bebé en el sótano de la tienda luego
apagó la electricidad y pidió que
apagarán sus teléfonos antes de correr
por una salida de seguridad al verlo la
policía lo señaló como cómplice del
terrorista y muévete en siete minutos me
esposaron permaneció esposado durante
una hora y media hacían las mismas
preguntas y yo les daba las mismas
respuestas una y otra vez cuántos de
ustedes están ahí pensé que estaban
preguntando cuántos rehenes así que les
dije que habían unos 15 dijeron 15
terroristas fue entonces cuando me di
cuenta de que estaban hablando de los
terroristas así que les dije que yo no
era uno de ellos pero no me creyeron
finalmente fue identificado el jefe
policial a cargo de la operación obtuvo
de él información valiosa como el
escondite de los rehenes no sé a postes
sentimos ahora ellos permitió trazar
planos de la tienda eliminando algunas
hipótesis como nuestra idea inicial de
romper la pared del sótano con
explosivos la sana batilly nos dijo que
no nos llevaría a donde queríamos irse
su contribución fue crucial al agua
personal en boston
[Música]
cuatro horas después de la toma de
rehenes comenzó la acción de la policía
cool y bali disparó en contra de los
oficiales y murió durante el tiroteo los
28 rehenes fueron liberados sólo uno
quedó herido pero todos vivos en los
días siguientes la sana fue condecorado
y recibió la ciudadanía ahora los
presuntos cómplices de cool y bali serán
juzgados
la sana estará allí para escuchar su
testimonio y su presión portal que se
posee para mí es muy importante saber la
verdad entender lo que pasó de areal
textos que se para se usa tanto en eeuu
el presidente de donald trump visitó la
ciudad de que no ya en el estado de
wisconsin donde un agente de policía
blanco dejó paralizado al afroamericano
jake blake tras dispararle por la
espalda en siete ocasiones el mandatario
calificó a las protestas como terrorismo
doméstico y no visitó a blake ni tampoco
a su familia pero si se reunió con las
autoridades a quienes les prometió mayor
ayuda económica para un estado que
necesita ganar si quieren mantenerse en
el poder y desde que no sea el
periodista edgar costa no reportan más
detalles sobre la visita del mandatario
escuchemos
ha sido una semana muy difícil para que
no sea esta localidad del estado de
wisconsin que ha visto como la visita de
don al tram aprovecha para generar más
polémica
hemos tenido tensión en las calles
constante y la visita de don al tram ha
sido para apuntar y señalar aquellos que
causan disturbios como ante americanos y
anti policía y precisamente sus acciones
son muy claras y serán las de donar un
millón de dólares de fondos federales
para la policía local de que no sea
cuatro millones de dólares para los
comercios afectados por las destrozos
como por ejemplo este concesionario de
coches completamente calcinado momentos
después de que se hicieran virales las
imágenes de los disparos al
afro-americanos jason blake precisamente
sus familiares hoy se han reunido para
atacar al presidente donald trump
mostrar apoyo público al demócrata joe
biden y ambos candidatos en la contienda
de noviembre están intentando sacarle
rédito político a una situación que en
el caso de donald trump estaba realmente
complicada con la situación económica y
con la gestión del coronavirus y en
cambio ahora está agarrándose a la ley y
al orden como baza política para su
posible reelección
avanzamos con noticias de américa latina
y vamos a brasil donde un tribunal de
este país anuló este martes una de las
nueve causas penales por presunta
corrupción abiertas contra el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva por
considerar que no existen pruebas
suficientes para avanzar en este proceso
el juicio se vinculaba a una serie de
acusaciones de tráfico de influencia
lavado de dinero y asociación ilícita
bajo la presunción de que el
exmandatario habría favorecido negocios
ilícitos de la constructora odebrecht
esto en el marco de la trama de
corrupción conocida como la operación la
vallado y precisamente el fiscal que
coordinaba la investigación de esta
operación presentó su renuncia
argumentando motivos familiares así se
pronunciaba después de años de intensa
dedicación a la vallado creo que ahora
es el momento de dedicarme de manera
especial a mi familia y seguiría
trabajando como fiscal pero necesitaré
esas horas extras que he invertido en
noches fines de semana y vacaciones para
centrarme en mi familia continuamos
ahora con información acerca del avance
del coronavirus kobe
19 a nivel global de acuerdo a cifras de
la universidad johns hopkins los
contagiados alcanzan al momento los 25
millones 781 mil 343 con un nivel de
recuperados que superó la barrera de los
17 millones de personas mientras que los
decesos por el virus del cob y 19 suman
800 57 mil 767
y en otras noticias la franja de gaza-
está viviendo una situación límite a
causa de la pandemia de coronavirus y el
bloqueo se ha impuesto por parte de
israel- los habitantes de este enclave
palestino se enfrentan desde hace
semanas al hambre y es que las
cuarentenas impuestas ante el avance de
la pandemia impiden que la poca
actividad comercial que existía continúe
desarrollándose los detalles en el
informe de álvaro cordero
la franja de gaza vive una situación
límite los casos de coronavirus se han
multiplicado en las últimas semanas
hasta por 20 veces y las autoridades
palestinas se han visto obligadas a
decretar confinamientos a la población
un cierre que acentúa la crisis
alimentaria y humanitaria que ya vive
este enclave que cuenta con un 75% de
población pobre y extremadamente pobre
si la pesca sigue detenida a morir de
hambre nadie nos está ayudando les digo
que moriré de hambre
no soy un empleado del gobierno y no
tengo un salario mensual
si tuviera salario 500 shekels al mes y
quedaría en casa no un año sino 10.000
años pero con esta situación si el mar
permanece cerrado no moriré de
coronavirus morir de hambre
a esto hay que sumarle el bloqueo que
sufre por parte de israel desde hace más
de 13 años que lejos de relajarse se ha
endurecido desde mediados de agosto
israel ha realizado varios ataques
contra hamas en gaza luego de que fuesen
lanzados globos explosivos a su
territorio desde la franja
ante la situación las autoridades piden
una respuesta internacional la franja de
gaza ha estado experimentando
condiciones humanitarias catastróficas
debido al asedio durante más de 13 años
ahora el coronavirus ha entrado en la
sociedad y se debe exigir a las
instituciones internacionales que tome
la iniciativa inmediata para ayudar a la
población de la franja de gaza- a hacer
frente a este asedio y a esta pandemia
aunque los territorios palestinos no
fueron muy golpeados durante la primera
ola de la pandemia ahora sí que están
sufriendo directamente las consecuencias
del virus una crisis sanitaria que se ve
agravada por los casi nulos recursos de
los que dispone el enclave a todos los
niveles
y en la tercera de nuestras entrega de
informes sobre la cultura en medio de la
pandemia hoy vamos a brasil'
el carnaval estamos hablando de la
manifestación cultural más emblemática
de este país está siendo amenazado por
la pandemia de coronavirus las ciudades
de sao paulo y salvador ya suspendieron
las fiestas y evalúan la posibilidad de
que los desfiles se realicen a partir de
mayo mientras que en río de janeiro la
liga de las escuelas de samba se va a
pronunciar este mes recordemos que el
carnaval es vital para la economía de
todo el país
la ciudad de la samba está totalmente
parada el único almacén de producción
con actividad es el de la escuela de
samba unidos de viradouro pero son solo
obreros reparando los daños causados por
un incendio en abril pasado con la
pandemia
álex fat director de carnaval de la
agrupación campeona en 2020 no puede
organizar los eventos que permiten
recaudar fondos a lo largo del año
y que montamos todas las piezas de la
carroza están aquí preparadas para ser
llevadas a una escuela de samba de nova
friburgo es este tipo de
comercialización que hacemos lo que nos
ayuda para mantener nuestro carnaval en
este tiempo de dificultad
en la escuela y ha elegido la trama de
su próximo desfile un homenaje al
carnaval de 1919 es conocido como el
mayor del siglo por sus excesos
intensidad después de la pandemia de
gripe española pero con todo parado
hasta que se tome una decisión
definitiva muchos han perdido un empleo
seguro
el taller así nos afecta mucho estamos
tristes no solo porque estas personas no
están aquí sino también porque sabemos
que ellas se están pasando por momentos
difíciles en sus casas hasta para
mantenerse
[Música]
sin poder ensayar juntos al aire libre a
causa de la cuarentena los miembros del
brujo de calle que es trabajadora
también se adaptan a lo largo del año
marcelo uno de los fundadores de la
banda creada en 2008 recibe un salario
gracias a las clases de percusión
desde el momento en que pudimos hacerlo
la única manera que encontramos para
mantener un mínimo para subsistir fue
poner las clases en formato online y sin
colocar los formato main
algo con lo que la pandemia no acabará
en brasil es con la pasión de sus
músicos
finalizamos otra emisión de noticias
continúen en france 24 y en france mit y
cuatro.com
[Música]